let's start from the beginning right so
uh you you said you encourage men not to
get married is that opinion both of you
guys have yeah we we there's a very few
situations where you you should make
better being single yeah honestly all
right so you want to just give us the
bullet points I know I know we've talked
about it quite a bit but let's go
through it now just to start from the
beginning why shouldn't men get married
um well the the a big reason why is
because like
um marriage is a traditional thing and a
lot of women aren't traditional you know
uh you know let's let's be honest I'm
just gonna have to say things that might
offend people women are more promiscuous
than they've ever been yep you're going
to have to train a lot of bad habits out
of your girlfriend and or wife to make
her a suitable candidate to be your
long-term partner to raise children
because the problem is this Society
nowadays you got this rap music you got
city girls teaching girls all this other
stuff these are bad habits not conducive
to a good long-term girlfriend and or
wife of your child you know what I'm
saying last thing you want is your son
to be walking down the playground but
hey dude I saw your mom's like but an
only fans like that's terrible you know
what I'm saying like and a lot of Rhodes
is dealing with the consequences of that
right now for poor decisions in the past
but that's what I'm saying so like women
are more promiscuous now they don't they
don't want uh they don't want to follow
male leadership you know uh they don't
want to um they don't want to adhere to
traditional traits but they expect you
to adhere to all your masculine
traditional traits so it's a bad trade
for you A lot of the time and only not
only that why would you sign a contract
with someone that's incentivized to
break it yeah and you you they break
that contract they get half your stuff
exactly not only that most women marry
up so by default more than likely
whatever woman you deal with is going to
make less money than you so and not only
that but when she when she's married
that's when the sexless marriages start
that was when the this you know the the
disrespect begins or whatever so it's
not in a man's best interest to get
married in today's State because a lot
of women are not fit wives to be honest
Tim I was actually married before right
so I'm speaking from my personal opinion
as well as being married but I'll say
this regarding marriage there's no
there's no benefit for me being in that
marriage versus not being in that
marriage so when I was single dating the
same girl at the same band benefits but
now being married I above the state into
my intimate life so if I want to leave
as ask permission to leave and guess
what they're going to take a portion if
I want to do certain things so I'm just
saying like regarding marriage itself
what's the benefit for men honestly not
much other than having kids and even
then it's kind of like okay you could
have kids books but you know what up
marriage my thing is look I'd rather go
to Columbia find a nice a nice chick
over there Marry Her come out to the U.S
a real talk here's another thing too I'm
gonna say it as well yeah more than
likely if you marry a woman in today's
day and age she's gonna have a past okay
women always want women want a man with
a future but a man does not want a woman
that has a past but the problem is that
if I say I don't want to pass that's
considered misogynistic toxic whatever
but no I'm taking a huge Risk by
marrying you and having children with
you so I need to make sure just like you
want me to be able to provide for the
family that you're going to be a dutiful
wife and not embarrass me and the family
because when women cheat their serious
negative consequences to it that can
destroy a family get pregnant by another
man whatever it is it just it just
doesn't work so
a lot you know if you're going to get
married you're going to want a woman
that has a lower Notch count matter
literally designed to want a woman that
has a lower Notch count are you going to
find that in the west very tough man I
just after that point as well so when I
married this District Corrections a
single mom uh just when it first came to
America and you know at the beginning it
was cool Rosie everything was cool but
then it started getting into like
demanding okay you know what spend more
time with my kid I need to you know to
do these things whatever and I was like
you know what this wasn't part of our
agreement at the beginning like you know
it was us helping each other out
whatever the point here is that like
they can now accept more boundaries on
you and demands on you and because
you're in a situation it's kind of okay
this is my wife I should do this because
if I don't she might leave me and her
her leaving me is very very powerful
because now I'm gonna lose half my stuff
that being said I left her because I
knew going forward if I stayed any
longer I could be hell liable for a lot
of things like maybe child support maybe
even you know having to pay alimony so I
got out as fast as possible under that
year but I'm saying most guys they stick
hey you know what I'll stick with her
you know do bullcrap whatever and then
they get finessed because they pay you
know all that stuff they got to pay so
cheaper to keeper that's not terrible
and one last thing I want to say because
I know that the feminists might get mad
at me whatever for me saying that yeah
man yeah they already sent me death
threats every day so it is what it is so
I'll just go all the way um the thing is
this um female promiscuity does have
consequences it's just that we don't
tell women this because we don't want to
tell them the truth right when you lie
women by you know go ahead girl do your
thing
all I'm saying is that if you're gonna
marry a woman her past does matter for
you as a guy and there's studies that
show this that the more Partners a woman
has the lower her ability to probably
have to pair bond with you and or have a
marriage that's going to last it has
significant uh consequences if the woman
was had a promiscuous pass so guys need
to be smart and know that if you're
going to pick a woman for a long-term
relationship to have children with you
got to know what you're doing and in
today's Western culture women are
incentivized to be promiscuous so it's
like and I shouldn't be admitting this
as a guy that that you know dates
casually whatever but for the women out
there that might be watching her guys
that are thinking about getting married
this stuff matters guys you need to look
at this check out the story we got go
ahead wife's response to husband's
message to lose weight goes viral she
should have given you divorce papers
here's the story a guy bought uh he
posted a veil online saying he
purposefully bought his wife a dress
that was too small for he wanted her to
lose weight the response how sick and
disgusting she should divorce you she
can gorge herself eat whatever she wants
she owes you nothing and she gets half
your stuff
um there you go what what incentive is
there you know what I'll say this too to
all of the all the the women who may get
angry about hearing the stuff
if you don't like hearing this I'm not
saying this to say any of it's good or
right or anything like that but now
you're hearing what men are thinking and
what men are talking about and what men
want yeah what they'll never say and
there was a Peloton commercial too that
got people offended because the guy last
Last Christmas I think it was yeah the
guy uh bought her a treadmill you bought
her a yeah Peloton which is like a bike
yeah a bike and uh and there was a bunch
of Rage like are you telling your wife
that she needs to lose weight blah blah
blah and this just shows the crazy clown
world that we're in where having
standards on women is considered
misogynistic or awful you know what I'm
saying and it's all you're simply
telling her is Hey listen if you want to
continue to get this security and
provisioning and relationship with me
you need to also perform there's a
burner performance on men but there's
never a burner performance on women
women are we have a bunch of social
conventions out there that allow women
to misbehave act poorly be obese be
crass be annoying and with zero
consequence if a woman is fat love your
curves girl hey wait wait if a woman is
rude it's okay they just can't handle
you you know if she's strong and
independent you know what he has small D
energy he's not worthy of your time you
know you go girl but if a guy's a loser
hey man you're a loser you live with
your mom in your basement you're a dork
whatever men are there's negative
reinforcement to mistakes made if you're
a man but there are not Nega there's not
negative reinforcement for bad female
decisions and the thing is this who
loses the women loses because they end
up single because men select who gets
married okay you want to hear my
favorite conspiracy theory yeah let's do
it all right you know the dove real
Beauty campaign
so they got bigger women plus size women
fat women for their kids Victoria's
Secret's doing that too yeah yeah yeah
but here's the thing about the the the
the the dove real Beauty campaign right
so they got like bigger women plus size
women yeah all right you know you know
Ben and Jerry's obviously ice cream ice
cream yeah guess what come there's one
company that owns both Unilever so the
the joke conspiracy theory is that the
the they sell the ice cream to all these
women get them really overweight and
then do commercials saying you're so
beautiful wow you keep buying like
because you do these ad campaigns for
soap we got all these super attractive
models and these women who keep eating
your ice cream you know they're going to
be out of shape and feel bad so you got
to make the commercial sound hey it's
great it's great but but look at this
you get the body positivity movement
yeah you get all these ads with morbid
Leo based women that are like at serious
risk of of Health complications it's
horrifying there's there's nothing like
that for men no there's there's no man
body positivity movement I mean maybe
like no male plus size models I don't
see oh where's the Men's Fitness
magazine with a big fat morbidly obese
Guy saying like this this actually
reminds me of the circle squared hoax
guys you guys know about um James
Lindsey Peter burgosian Helen pluck Rose
they they spoofed a bunch of journals
one of them was fat bodybuilding okay I
don't know if this got accepted but the
idea was why is muscle the preferred you
know bodybuilding fat bodybuilding is
you should be able able to eat a bunch
of food get really really fat and that's
bodybuilding too
but but it doesn't exist no there's no
there's no like my there's no big ad
campaign where it's like a big fat dad
bod guy you know just sitting there like
I eat a lot of Twinkies yeah they don't
do that and when you and it's amazing
because like I use the example before
the analogy like if I walked around on a
dressing heels and I said oh well you
know I'm really good at doing this you
should accept me for whatever it sounded
asinine right but that's how women sound
when they say I make a lot of money and
I'm a I'm a corporate exec whatever men
don't care about that these are
considered masculine traits no matter
how much feminists want to argue with us
about it like earning money becoming
high-powered High status whatever these
are things that men tend to do and women
find attractive and then they're
masculine traits so if you have them
cool Plus for you but it's irrelevant
towards your sexual market value and yes
like I said there's never going to be a
body positivity for men because I always
say for a man to be attractive to women
he's got to live in a fact-based reality
he cannot men don't get the privilege of
living in a Disney fairy tale I can't
tell you how many women I know it's okay
you'll find a good girl don't worry
she'll come your way blah blah blah no
that's cap because that's like me
telling a lion Hey listen lion if you
just wait and you'll find that gazelle
man don't worry about it right to you
he'll come right to you you just need
more time no you need to tell that line
what you need to be stalking your prey
you need to be out at night hiding in
the grass you might need two of your
buddies to help you whatever it is and
then when they're not looking you gotta
jump on them that's what it takes to get
women you got to reveal unflattering
realities about how women really May
select to get them but women get the
privilege of saying I'm gonna wait
around and the right guy will come
because they can they get the privilege
of being able to believe in Disney fairy
tales because they're the gazelle you
can't do that as a man you're the lion
if you don't know what you're doing
you're gonna die you want to get girls
you have to know these unflaughting
realities with men and I think that's
why this type of content is exploding in
popularity we're not just men but also
women because men are learning what it
takes to actually be attractive to women
you know not being a pushover not being
soft you know having these bad boy
Tendencies You Know and then women are
learning okay Men actually are different
they want me to be attractive and
feminine and submissive but other tired
of being lied to yeah there you go and
you know and but real quick I think
that's one of the reasons why feminists
get so mad at this stuff there's a uh I
knew this uh a friend of mine his dad
was a physicist we are talking about M
Theory quantum physics you know the the
top tier the unified theory and I was
like is this is this real is this it is
the universe this 12 dimensional
membrane or whatever this crazy theory
is and he said there's a lot of problems
with we can't figure out but you got a
lot of scientists who have dedicated 60
years of their lives to this scientific
theory and they will never give that up
so you prove them wrong and they're like
my whole life was wasted and broken so
now you have these women they're 35 they
have good careers they make six figures
and if you say men have a tendency to
not want not want to date that they're
going to get mad yeah they have to get
they have to shame you you have to be
wrong you are wrong it's not true I did
everything right I know you did I know
you did what they told you to do but and
I'm not saying it's right I'm just
saying you you look at the studies the
Tendencies exist so it's going to be a
lot harder for you like going to college
not a good idea and all these kids were
like but I was told to go to college I
did exactly what I was told great now
you're massively in debt you can't get a
job
a lot of a lot of uh women that we bring
on our show that get mad when we say
these types of things they say well
that's not fair and I tell them life
isn't fair it's not fair that you get to
go into a nightclub without paying it's
not fair that there are men that are
willing to pay your rent for not doing
anything we had a girl on on our show
yesterday she's on unemployment she's
riding around in rolls royces and
McLarens and she she went to Vegas today
yep an unemployed man would never be
able to do that why but she's young and
attractive and she's a woman so there's
privileges on both sides and
unfortunately ladies some of the things
that men can do you can't ah dude like
growing up how many how many women how
many guys did you know that became
homeless how many women did you know
that became homeless exactly I mean I'm
not saying it's it's absolute there's
obviously homeless women but but I think
yeah a one in five uh homeless people
are women yeah some like it's really
really low because women can just find a
guy and live with them yeah not it's not
it's not absolute it's not of course you
know but
suicides overwhelmingly dudes exactly
I'm curious victims of violent crime men
because I had a woman one time say I was
like give me a privilege that women have
that men don't or right and she was like
well you could walk around at night
enough to feel scared and I was like
feeling versus reality are two different
thing things men are actually far more
prone to be victims of violent crime
which is what you're trying to say
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time